人生骨
来这个哈伦裤来给宝贝看一下哈伦裤
这个哈伦裤啊腰是腰上收绳有松紧
要两边口袋
屁股后面是一个装饰口袋
小直筒呢
但这里有一点面
有一个粗纱线
有一个粗纱线啊
来这个裤子
谁要咱们谁来扣
来给大家放福利9块
9块啊
来腰围64可以拉到84
腿围104可以拉伸到108
来
当长是32
裤长的话是88
来这个裤子谁要9块9块
扣零扣零
来喜欢的姐姐就给我9块扣零
9块9块扣零扣零
扣零扣零扣零扣零
喜欢的姐姐就扣个零
好
最不爱吃的是苹果
不过花牛会吃
你们家饭拉子会吃
是吧
花牛啥意思
来这个裙子
直筒裙灰色的
还是高货吗
来这个牌这个牌
这个牌灰色的
来来来来来
这一款左边有隐形拉链有风机扣
腰后面带松紧腰直筒直筒的
来这一款裙子后面底边开个叉
后面底边开个叉灰色灰色
来胸围胸围不是不是
腰围64可以拉到78
臀围96可以拉到98
寻常来90
小的时候有种黄黄的苹果叫
黄胶好像那个好吃粉粉面面的啊
花牛是苹果的一种啊
来不好意思
来这一款谁要谁来扣39 39
扣个3灰色的
来谁要谁来扣
39扣个3
39谁要谁来扣个3
我因为我们这边水果多
所以我跟你说从小到大
我们吃的苹果啊梨啊什么的
真的不少
吃的好多的
来这个小吊带这个没有色差
这个是好的
那个有色差的被天空扣走了
哎天空这两天估计忙
这两天没看到他
来欢迎大家摸鱼来看侠侠
摸鱼的时间到了啊
来这一款这一款
这个小笨星
咔色的有腰带
有腰带有腰带的这个小吊带
后面是带松紧的
后面带松紧的
来这款咔色咔色
面料锯纸面料锯纸的
来我来量一下
胸围胸围82可以拉伸到104
腰围的话是66可以拉到80
来一场的话是50
来这款谁要29 29扣个2
29扣个2我今天回老家
回老家我婆婆又在吊水
又说腿麻又生病了
鱼毛你来啦好久不见啊亲爱的
欢迎欢迎好久不见啊
来来就鱼鱼鱼393
好久不见亲爱的
来393谢谢太给力了
送你个小口罩
太给力了
刚好还有一个全棉的
你们有没有这样子的
就是说这个字突然一下就不会写了
就是感觉到写了
然后写出来
不客气 谢谢你
然后写出来感觉
不对 好像不是这样写的
就突然一下觉得我写的不对
来
再对一对
最近好款很多
还有一个小吊带
给你看看 黑色的
也是要卖19的
但是那个有点短
我放福利了
你看你要不要
我给你看看亲爱的
看一下喜不喜欢
鱼鱼猫
看一下这个牌子
M码
M码面料锯纸
M码面料锯纸的
这个小短的
这个咱们单穿叠穿
当美背穿都可以
前面有拉链的
前面有拉链
有拉链的
它的后面也是带松紧的
后背也是松紧的
我来量一下
这个咱们谁要
给大家9块了
来 胸围胸围
可以拉伸到88
腰围的话是
66 68
一层的话是
来这个谁要9块我来勾
9块9块扣
谁要谁来扣这个9块公联
嗯
对
9块9块
来这个大家的这个T又出来一件
来谁要谁来
9块9008
大家的这个 plusieurs
上最百搭的
该 crispy
来这款格子的这款
有裤有裤呀
有腰身
腰是松你的
单层单层的这个衬衫
前面有一排裤子
来单层单层的这个衬衫
灰格灰格
咱们来量一下
你听一下
胸围胸围
胸围92
192 100
腰围70
可以拉到80
来
衣长57
来这款谁要谁来扣
谁要谁来扣
来19 19
扣1扣1
来喜欢的姐姐就扣了
这款原来是39的
要腰身有腰身
款式也好看
就是单层单层的
谁要谁来扣
19 19
扣1扣1
来这个是西装裤
西裤
条纹的直筒的
来这款前面有风机裤
有拉链
两边有口袋
屁股后面有直纱口袋
屁股后面有直纱口袋的
来这款条纹条纹
腰围腰围70 72
臀围100 106
来单层27
单层27
来裤长105
来这个裤子谁要9块9块
扣8扣8
谁要谁来扣谁要谁来扣姐妹们
9块9块
扣8扣8
来喜欢的姐姐就给我9块9块扣8扣8
来来来来来来
喜欢的姐姐去扣牙
来这个小格子裙
来这款160160快乐999跑哪去了
来这个
来这个裙子
来这款格子裙160160是个大同的啊
是个大同的
但是它胸围后面是有松紧的
咱们有小姐姐瘦一点的瘦小一点的小姐姐是可以穿的啊
来这款咱们来量一量你们听一下啊
来胸围胸围胸围
82但是可以穿的啊
可以拉伸到98腰围72可以拉伸到8272
82来寻常101群长101来这个裙子谁要谁来扣9块9块扣0扣0来喜欢的姐姐就扣9块9块谁要谁来扣个零
谁要谁来扣个零
来喜欢的姐姐就给我9块扣09块扣0
哪来啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦啦
的
来这个衣服来给宝贝看一看
大妈的
面料是锯纸的
它的领口有一个这个
有一个这个装饰扣
看到了吗
然后它的袖子是一个花边袖
面料锯纸
这个应该是大妈
不是两家就是三家
面料锯纸滑滑的啊
哦
我的妈呀
六个L
面料锯纸加卷纸的六L
六L
咱们来量一下
胸围胸围
130 132
长度66
来9块9块
扣6扣6
来喜欢的姐姐就给我9块扣6啊
六个L的
六L的大的
六L六L的
9块9块扣6扣6
8块8块9块9块
9块9块9块
10块10块
一块
12块
14块
15块
18块
19块
20块
21块
22块
23块
24块
25块
26块
27块
28块
29块
30块
32块
33块
34块
35块
36块
37块
39块
40块
50块
31块
42块
33块
34块
35块
36块
33块
8块
13块 11块
嗯
来这个小格子的
格子的这个
来这个吊带
后面是松紧的
少腰带少腰带
格子格子这一款啊
我看一下它是什么码
这个是3L
来面料是
锯纸63棉27
人棉10%
来胸围的话是
98 106
腰围的话是
100 102
长度的话是52
来这个谁要9块9块扣3
9块9块扣3
又大又少腰带
所以给大家放福利了
9块9块扣3
这个格子的单层单层
没有理层的
小脆心
9块9块
扣3扣3
来这个黑色的连衣裙
要腰身有腰身
来这一款后面有隐形拉链的直筒裙
这个很性感
这个很性感的
来面料很舒服啊
后面有隐形拉链
来胸围86 92
腰围64 66
64可以拉到66
臀围的话是82 88
臀围82 88
长度的话是79
来这个裙子谁要29
29扣个1
29扣1
谁要谁来扣个1
来29扣1
29谁要谁来扣个1
来来来
这个很淑女的啊这件
很淑女很淑女
很淑女的啊
姐姐看看后面的白底妆
碎花裙
OK
好的
小妹妹来了
是这个不
这个裙子点击率老高了
它是腰后面是带松紧的
有风机扣
有拉链
来看看
非常好看
我来给你量一下
应该是个M码
来
腰围
腰围腰围64
可以拉伸到74
臀围的话不限
臀围很大
臀围不限
裙长的话是
79 80
39新款